but first boris johnson is expected to
confirm tomorrow that lockdown
restrictions will be lifted on july the
19th
despite the rise we're seeing in
infections to talk about that
and much more we're joined by one of the
government's top strikers
the vaccine minister nadim zahawi
good morning minister now tomorrow the
prime minister says he's going to
confirm
whether july the 19th uh will herald
the lifting of restrictions are you
seeing anything in the data
that might prevent him uh giving us the
green light
so you're quite right tomorrow the prime
minister will
as he outlined uh a week ago
that he will share with the country the
latest data
the really good news is that 86 percent
now
almost 87 of all adults have got the
protection of
one dose and 65 percent
on our protected with two doses the
target is that we get to 66 percent
uh double jabbed by the 19th of
july we will meet that target so i'm
confident
that we can proceed uh to step forward
cautiously and
we will be setting out uh tomorrow
guidelines
on everything from mask wearing the
transition from sort of mandating or
government by
dictat to taking personal responsibility
whether
uh for our own actions or corporate
responsibility
at sky and obviously at transport for
london and elsewhere
about proceeding cautiously i think you
said it at the outset
of your program this pandemic is not
over
uh we're seeing uh a rise in infection
rates in this country but also
uh in europe and elsewhere the
difference is for us
is that the vaccination program has been
so successful that we are
as i say almost 87 percent of all adults
have been protected with one dose
and we will hit that 66 with double dose
so it was right
to give ourselves a bit more time if you
remember we paused for four weeks
to be able to protect more people
minister does does all of that program
include the prospect of reducing the
interval between first and second doses
uh as is being reported this morning
no i i i'm slightly puzzled where that
story has come from because
um obviously i engage almost on a daily
basis with my colleagues at the jcvi
and professor wei shen and professor
anti handen who
um look at this very closely the real
world data
the the clinical data suggests that
actually the eight week interval
offers that you know additional
fortification in terms of protection
with the two doses much better than
having the interval shortened any
further and of course the prime minister
announced that
now we've brought down that interval
from 12 to 8 weeks for all adults
so anybody who gets their first dose now
and i
absolutely encourage everyone as
hopefully they'll be doing we've got a
clean
a site next to wembley stadium who will
be also offering those jabs and
at millwall stadium and lots of other
football states of ittihad and elsewhere
if they get their job now they'll get
their second job
within that eight-week interval that is
the clinical advice and that's the
advice we will follow
so we can be clear you know to take
today's jargon that
um when it comes to vaccine you have to
hold and you have to give at the right
time
you've decided actually that there is
going to be no change on that
well obviously the joint committee on
vaccination immunization these are the
the experts look at this all the time
and their advice is very clear that the
real world
data suggests that the eight-week
interval is
actually the best in terms of giving
everyone who's had their first dose
their second dose and that protection
the added boost in terms of both uh
antibodies and t cells is within that
eight week interval rather than
shortening it any further
okay let's clear up one thing uh that
has created a small mystery this week
you and other ministers have been saying
for some weeks
that the link between vaccination and
serious illness hospitalization and
death has been weakened but not broken
but on wednesday the prime minister said
it has been broken now if anybody
should know what the truth of that is
it's you
what is true has the link been weakened
or has it actually been
broken well i think the prime minister
at the press conference last week
talked about as did patrick valance well
that's so so
clear he said at prime minister's
questions
that uh we scientists are absolutely
clear
that we have severed the link now is he
right
or are you still saying what you did
before
which is that it's weakened
i think there's there's you know whether
it's
the the language of sort of completely
suffering the link or
otherwise um the the reality is
that we through the vaccination program
have
severely weakened uh the link between
infection rates
and hospitalization of serous infection
if you look at the data so i looked at
this before coming on your show
as of friday in terms of people in
hospital
62 62 of those in hospital of the 2
300 people in hospital in england 62
are under the age of 55. uh
in the previous waves that would have
been the other way around so it would
have been the majority would have been
over the age of 55. only 15 percent
are over 75 so it is weakened but people
are still obviously
getting infected the majority of people
who are who are
severely infected are those who are
unvaccinated which is why
i go back to the same message you know
if you haven't been vaccinated get
vaccinated
i i i get i get all of that but
we're not dancing on the head of a pin
here the distinction is important
uh whether i have broken my arm or i
have severed my arm
rather different situations so what
we're being clear about this morning
is that we're still in the realm of the
link
being weakened but not severed so the
prime minister
let's call it misspoke
it it has been severely weakened
through the vaccination program and the
promise i think i i listened to the
press conference uh
he spoke very clearly as did patrick
balance that the link
has been weakened by the vaccination
program the success of the vaccination
program
i think it's important that we remain
cautious and careful and the guidelines
that we'll set out
tomorrow will demonstrate that including
guidelines
that people are expected to wear masks
in
indoor enclosed spaces um and of course
to remain vigilant with you know hands
and
and face and and to just remember that
if we all act
responsibly as we did with the
vaccination program the nation came
together
to vaccinate 80 000 vaccinated
volunteers
who came forward retire out of
retirement and to vaccinate
we can come together and deal with this
uh pandemic in a way that is responsible
by by thinking about our own actions and
how they impact other people
including of course people who are maybe
immunocompromised all right
minister i'm sorry if i i appear to be
hurrying you up a little bit but there's
a lot to talk about a lot to get clear
um the office for national statistics
tells us that the
seven day average for vaccinations
dropped from over 200
000 in late june to just around 100
000 at the beginning of july would you
accept that we're running into a period
of slower vaccination rates
yes i do and these are the hard yards uh
trevor so
uh back to the numbers i quoted earlier
we're almost at
87 of all adults have now got their
first dose
the majority we were running at about 96
return for their second dose i want to
get that to 100 if i can
the office for national statistics also
say that 96
of all adults will uh very likely take
the vaccine if they think very
positively about vaccines
so the hard yards are to get that 86 87
where we are today 290 plus percent
vaccinated because actually what we need
to make sure is
as the virus gets desperate and attempts
to
infect people to mutate and be able to
survive
it we should continue to fortify the the
nation
with the vaccination program because
that is the way we we
transition it from pandemic to endemic
uh status and deal with it in the future
with the booster campaign in september
as per the interim advice from jcvi and
of course then maybe an annual
vaccination program for covert
as well as the flu which we're planning
um
to begin from september and look at how
we can co-administer flu and
and covert the reason the reason i um
asked you about that
minister is that there's a crunch coming
here
isn't there your boss health secretary
says that
we might be looking at a hundred
thousand infections
a day uh that if we keep the pinging
regime
as it is we might be talking about a
million
and more people being pinged and
self-isolating
every week and that's just if we assume
that it's just two infections per person
and
nobody's sure about that the point is
that the government has rested pretty
much everything
on your continuing success uh
on keeping the vaccine rollout at pace
the problem is you guys are taking a bit
of a punt here aren't you
you are gambling that the vaccine
rollout
can keep ahead of all of those other
problems
including the possibility of variant
it is a gamble
so trevor there are no easy decisions
to make on this and let me try and bring
it to life for your viewers
on friday i do my constituency surgery
i went to visit a business in ulster
called orange mabel
which is a lovely tea shop in in ulster
who's
really weathered the storm and survived
through the pandemic
and has reopened and is trying
everything
they can to continue to survive and
thrive
they lost two members of staff to
suicide
because of the lockdown so there are
other
damage that is being done through
uh the the severe lockdown that we have
endured
now the vaccination program you're right
the vaccination program is our way out
of this so
at 87 almost of all adults
um vaccinated with one dose two-thirds
with two doses
i think it's the right time because
obviously as we
take advantage of the summer where
schools you know being out will
have a downward pressure on the r number
of course the socializing
and interaction has an upward pressure
but there is no perfect timing for this
it's the right thing to do because
actually as the secretary of state
you mentioned that in his interview
today in the the telegraph
talks about 13 million operations that
we need to make sure
happen and the nhs is it stands ready
today so
there is no timing we just have to
remain cautious to come to that in a
second but just let's just deal with the
next
couple of months could you actually tilt
the playing field
a bit in in your favor by doing a cup
doing certain things for example um at
one point we talked about test and
release
that is to say people like me who've had
two old people who've had two
vaccinations could be tested rather than
having to self-isolate
or that we could uh re release
um nhs staff from the possibility of
self-isolation
now are you thinking seriously about
those kinds of steps that would at least
uh take away some of the potential for
chaos
yeah so really good point so the
nhs app one has been an incredible
success
25 million downloads of the nhs app
hundreds of thousands of people um saved
from how being infected
but of course the app was developed and
operationalized at a time
when we didn't have vaccines um now
we're we're in a world where we have
almost 87 percent of people protected
with one dose two thirds with two doses
about 19. so we should absolutely and
the team
are looking at how we use that
app in terms of alerting people uh to
those
around them uh who who test positive of
course if you do test positive
you have to and should rightly uh
then self self-isolate but it's
important to look at that in a
new context of this massive vaccination
program and make sure that it is fit for
purpose for this new world including for
example
being able to take maybe you know five
days as we have piloted
of lateral flow tests and upload them to
the system
rather than having to self-isolate in
the case of nhs workers if they're
wearing their protective equipment
and ppe then they'd even today
they don't need to self-isolate if they
if they feel that they've they've
already been pinked it it's advisory
but if they feel they've protected
themselves properly then they don't need
to self-isolate hence why they're
able to uh plan for how we cope
with what the secretary state talks
about which is getting back to to a
place where we can
have those 13 million operations happen
so those with cancer
19 out of 20 getting getting the people
they need already but we want to be at
20 out of 20.
so those tweaks are on the table that's
uh
that's that's news for us can i just
take you to the point you were
discussing a moment ago which is the
uh backlog health secretary says
possibly 13
million people how will opening up
july on july 19th help
in any way in dealing with
that backlog of 13 million
patients who the health secretary
himself says have not come
forward in the last year year and a half
i mean how does that make sense
well because as he quite rightly
outlined in his interview
that it's that sort of british sense of
of wanting to protect
the nhs and fairness and whilst we we
are in
a severe lockdown people may have not
been coming forward i think it's right
now
with the billion pounds that is totally
focused
that we have made available to the nhs
on dealing with that backlog that the
nhs now is able
to do that it has done that for cancer
patients throughout the pandemic and
i absolutely um admire
and hold in real or
my colleagues in the nhs and what
they've been able to do but this is the
time now
to effectively make sure that we support
the nhs
to deal with that whilst also making
sure we do the
the booster campaign in september and
the flu
inoculation september because actually
what you want to make sure is in
the autumn period where we haven't had
much flu virus circulating
in communities we protect against flu
and covid
because in a bad year you know 20 000
people could could
perish because of the flu virus so
this is just let's get this absolutely
clear i mean it sounds like what you're
really saying here
is that you think that the possibility
of a hundred thousand infections a day
is less alarming than for example
the problem that you're looking forward
to
or your the prospect of problems
in the autumn of a different kind
flu and so forth to can you just get
clear with us what is it that
has persuaded you to take effectively
effectively to take this risk
that we might find ourselves with this
huge number
of infections with all that implies for
the
raised possibility of mutations and new
variants
that the vaccines can't deal with
so it's worth just reminding your
viewers
that our very strong stringent border
controls
continue and you have to take a test
before travel
a test after two days of being here the
red list
it remains in place for over 50
countries that's really important
because that's how
even if you are double uh vaccinated um
and you want to come in from an
ambulance country
you still have to take that test after
two days of arrival so
we're not you know throwing caution to
the wind in this case
the guidelines you will see next week
will
also demonstrate very clearly what
people need to do
and are expected to do for example on
mask wearing
all these things are a cautious but
pragmatic way
of getting us back to as close to normal
as possible
by the 19th of july now the important
thing to remember
is that this is this is not over yet and
we have to be careful
we have to be vigilant we have to see
what's happening in other countries
vis-a-vis variants you're absolutely
right and you'll you you know that that
will continue that will not change
so this is not a you know let's just go
out
and forget about the virus the virus is
still with us
and we have to be cautious but it's the
right thing to do because as i just
i hope described to you what was a
moving experience for me on friday
of a businesswoman telling me that two
of her staff committed suicide because
of lockdown
all right uh minister so much more that
we could be talking about but
unfortunately today is today
and i had to take just a few seconds to
ask you
a question that we're asking all our
guests today um
what's the score tonight going to be
i am not even going to attempt to answer
that question
because i do not want to jinx it i
traveled with england to germany and i
traveled to japan
no no no no uh you you can't see but i
have a whiteboard here
there are thousands and millions of
people
who are hanging on your every word and
we cannot leave this interview without a
number
two numbers on this whiteboard come on
i'm not gonna do it i am not gonna do it
i can't it's too painful i've
55 okay years ago we had a win
we will win tonight i am 54 years old
and i literally as i say i'm a football
fan i travel with
england to germany and to japan i am not
going to jinx it today this morning
to your viewers right but we're going to
win all right i have i have written the
word chicken
on my whiteboard here let me let me see
if you've got an answer to this question
bank holiday or not if we win
i'm not going to jinx that either there
is no way i'm going to be presumptuous
on your program and say
that we're going to have a bank holiday
okay
okay double chicken nando's here thank
you very much minister